I want take a deep dive into my
Bloomberg terminal and talk more about
commodities taking a look specifically
at glencore so Glencore stock hit a
record low after prophet sort of got
whacked and what you're looking at here
is the good news you look at in just a
second hold on I'm getting there ah I'm
getting an airy promise there we go that
looks a little bit better this is the
good news this is the free cash flow of
that Glencore was able to generate and
you can see here that's actually rising
increasing to over four billion dollars
let's compare that to its net debt
however and the picture looks a little
bit different yes you're seeing the net
debt come down a little bit it was lower
by about 1 billion dollars it's about 47
billion dollars right now you are still
seeing a free cash flow rise but that
spread is still pretty significant
therefore Glencore and therein lies the
problem and also you know you flag
Glencore earnings or something to watch
yesterday and they said something really
interesting on the call which is that
look everybody knew China was going to
be weak but it was weaker than they even
thought and they said they can't get a
good read on China kind of an ominous
statement that extends to the entire
world right now sure but they also blame
short sellers that was to another crisis
so I haven't heard that from anyone else
I mean I know what that part was weird
but in perspective with that but I want
to look into my terminal and talk about
stocks for a minute if you saw the last
segment on before here there's this
divergence breaking going on between
well momentum stocks have been on the
tear so these are your apples your
Netflix people are piling into these
strategies where they buy stocks just
because they've been going up but
there's kind of been a hiccup lately if
you look here this is a citigroup index
of momentum stocks it's still doing okay
it has it been a complete collapse but
as you could see there was a pretty
sharp leg down recently and people are
wondering if this whole strategy of just
piling into names because they've gone
up is going to deteriorate definitely
something people are watching